actually EU certified its products which
means doesn't follow the regulations in
North America because they're much
lighter there's also no such thing as EU
certified neither the us nor the EU
certifies Cosmetics before they're sold
you do have to submit some paperwork
before you launch in the EU though but
they don't okay it it even says on their
website that just because the
paperwork's been filed doesn't mean that
it's not breaking the law on the other
hand the FDA does actually certify a
whole bunch of color additives which is
very relevant to makeup the FDA will
literally run tests on samples of
pigments before they can be put into
makeup I'm actually a bit concerned when
us brands use this idea in their
marketing because this info is all over
the FDA website it makes it sound like
they don't actually understand the US
laws that they're meant to be following
so I feel like they could be messing up
a whole bunch more stuff